thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
adrian nadine who is a cello player
also a candidate master welcome to the
show
thank you very much thank you very much
i'm so happy because i'm here
and i see you after 20 years
this kind of player and this game tell
us a little bit
you're one of the most qualified persons
to speak about that
tell us a bit about the similarity
between music and chess
it's so beautiful music and so beautiful
the chess it's so strong similar thing
between the music and chess cause music
it's in like in life
and chess it's like in life
let's see something uh in the chess uh
the queen is the most in the stronger
are the strongest pieces in peace
in the game uh even the the evil the
king
are the same have a good mobility
but how you told me the king is a little
lazy so the queen the queen
is the beautiful and the force the force
and the beautiful lacking
lacking life like you know so similarity
and
not just this kind of similarity we have
in
music and uh in chess passion
i need to to i want to speak about
passion and it's about love
in music in chess is the same
you you can be a very good player extra
linear player you play fantastic but if
you if you don't have
fantasy and passion
this kind this is this and like it's not
enough to be a
great player the big great player for me
it was
the player was make a
beautiful game with passion with
when i feel love so exist love inches
i like this special i like that passion
and what other traits did you get
from in a short a chase is like a
beautiful
in a red rest we must found
in the game actually the beauty yes
if you don't the founder can be it's
i'm not like then we get the boring
drawers it's a boring yes
yes of course of course you must make a
beautiful game
must the checks is not about win but the
chase is not about to
lose some figure away the chest it is in
like music is about
to found a beauty your competition if
you found the beauty
you found liberty liberty yes your
competitive in chess
but also in music what traits did you
take from chess
to the career in music for me it was
in chess a very important moment because
you know the pastor trying to write 30
years ago
i told me i want to be a musician but i
like also the chess
but the chase and the music work
together so when i uh
was in the past a big concert before
concert
uh before the concert two and three uh
days
i make i will make a very good game
because i want to develop
some beauty from me or i want
found a beauty in that jazz in chess if
i
found the beauty in this day in chess i
have much
more beauty more beauty in the in the
music and inspiration and inspiration
so it's very important in my career
chess is very important because
keep me strong keep me
revised open give me with
mind very open excellent uh from there
from the players in this tournament
you've made the first move in the game
between uh luke let's go and mommy
is who's your favorite lupulesco in
general i
in general i love russia school of
chess but right now because they are
romanian
i i must say
the lupulescu and the bogdan
for me is the favorite because i'm i'm
romanian
and i want uh this two player
win excellent thank you very much adrian
you're bringing the passion
i think these players will be inspired
by this look at this
you're beautiful so beautiful uh caruana
fabian is the most open
in from this day he's the most open game
now we're definitely going to uh
and it's very risky but it's so open
excellent excellent the the break
it's it's just to appear and the black
have a uh
have some advantage but for the for the
uh finish of the game the white
if it uh take the pieces and open all
the pieces
it will be a winner not the knight i
don't know i don't know
i don't like that i prefer to lose
something
hopefully we're not going to see a draw
in this i hope i hope
back to you in the studio